for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
University calm thank you and enjoy okay
so what is the difference between
electron affinity and electronegativity
a lot of times people think well
electron affinity gaining electron
electronegativity pulling electrons
towards itself what's the distinction
what's the difference they're obviously
similar well yeah they're similar in the
win that they both described an atom
sort of having electrons come towards it
or to it completely so let's kind of
clear that up here electron affinity is
the energy associated with gaining an
electron right now this is a sort of a
sort of diet definition as compared to
what I mentioned earlier be sure to
watch that video for more details but
electron affinity is an energy okay
that's really really important it's the
energy associated with this process of
an atom a gaseous Adam picking up an
electron and becoming a gaseous anion
right so the energy change associated
with this is the electron affinity so
it's the electron affinity is an energy
okay so here is the EA one okay whereas
electronegativity is the relative
ability ability to attract electron
density across a bond right so this is
not an energy situation its ability
right so and it's of course across a
bond right so here what we're talking
about we're talking about two atoms and
their relative ability to attract
electrons toward itself so let's just
say that x and y 2 to 2 atoms are bound
together and let's assume that Y is more
electronegative what's going to happen
is that it's going to pull the electrons
that are in this chemical bond there are
electrons in there's two electrons in
their electron pair it's going to pull
them towards itself
it's going to pull the electrons towards
itself and so what's going to happen is
that some of you are going to see that
arrow and recognize what it means but I
won't get into that right now it's going
to pull the electron density towards
itself and what's going to happen is
that the the Y being more
electronegative if it pulls electron
densities words itself it's pulling
alike and negative charges towards
itself but it's not picking them up
completely so it's going to have a
slight negative charge a partial
negative charge that we're going to
denote with the Greek letter Delta the
lowercase version and a little minus
sign and when end when that's happening
the electrons are being pulled away from
the X right which if if the X is losing
the negative charges then it's becoming
partially positively charged okay now
this is can also be represented in this
way where the the electrons are very
clearly closer to the V Y than they are
to the X and so again the why would have
a partial negative charge and the X will
have a partial positive charge ok now
another thing is that with electron
affinity this applies to a tool to a
single unbound Adam right this is just a
gaseous atom by itself right but
electronegativity doesn't apply to a
single unbound a demo applies to an atom
in a bond in fact that's part of the
reason we don't consider the noble gases
to have electronegativities at least not
helium neon and argon because they don't
form bonds to things and because it all
form bonds they can't really have an
electronegativity associated with them
right because they have to be bound to
something in order to have an ability to
withdraw electron density towards
themselves now electron affinity it's
possible to have many successive values
right you can have the e a1 a2 a3 so on
and so forth right
both electronegativity there's only one
value and it's dependent only on the
identity of of the atom the identity of
the atom right because fluorine has a
value of 4.0 and everything is based on
that scale right it's on a scale for
four point on a scale where the highest
is 4.0 so the most electronegative atom
fluorine has a large chili negativity of
4.0 every other element has a value
associated with it that is lower than
4.0 but the value that it has is
dependent only on the identity of that
atom and yeah that's that's it they're
all values relative to fluorine which
has the highest value of 4.0 okay so I
hope that video kind of clears that up
and I hope that was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying